welcome to the newshour we begin with
breaking news coming out of the united
states where the u.s president joe biden
has tested positive for the coronavirus
his symptoms are said to be mild
it's the first time the 79 year old has
tested positive for the illness let's
get the very latest on this from our
white house correspondent kimberly
halcott who joins me live now
kimberly a very simple statement from
the white house confirming the condition
and the vaccinations that the president
has had that's all we've got so far
yeah that's right
just getting the news in the last few
moments via a statement giving a bit
more clarification from the president's
physician we understand the president
right now experiencing very
mild symptoms of covid19 we understand
it is a
runny nose fatigue and a dry cough now
there had been some questions about the
president and his whereabouts since he
returned from his middle east tour it
was a grueling multi-day tour of not
just israel but also saudi arabia
of course the president is advanced in
age and it was a very hectic schedule
and so uh many people when they travel
will take some time off
that certainly was the case with the
president he was uh only making a few
appearances and that did raise some
questions with reporters the white house
assuring reporters that the president
was okay he did make an appearance
where he talked about climate change in
massachusetts about 24 hours ago
really causing no alarm but then it was
today when the president was set to
travel again that we suddenly got the
notice that the president would instead
not be traveling but instead would be
remaining at the white house due to
experiencing these mild symptoms of
covid19 now we should point out that the
president is double vaxxed as it's
called in other words he's had two
courses of the covid19 vaccine as well
as he has been boosted on at least two
occasions most recently as of march 30.
now you will recall that donald trump
the previous president is uh also a
president who has come down with cobit
19. he did in fact experience more
severe symptoms that ultimately caused
him to have to leave the white house and
go to walter reed hospital in bethesda
maryland that is about 20 minutes drive
north of here that is not the case right
now for joe biden right now the white
house saying that this is a situation
that can be handled with the president's
physicians here at the white house at
this time and we understand there will
be a further update from the white house
at a white house press briefing that
will be coming up in the coming hours of
course when these sorts of situations
occur certainly with the u.s president
kimberley what's the protocol in terms
of informing the vice president or the
speaker of the house they they have to
be informed i presume
uh of course they would have to be
informed that is correct but uh right
now we have not been notified in any way
that the president is unable to carry
out his duties so at this point we are
under the impression that joe biden is
still very much in control of the white
house and is still
fully able to execute his duties as
president
in no way has his duty
been transferred to kamala harris the
vice president of the united states
so at this time we are fully under the
impression that this is nothing more
than uh someone who might be
experiencing a common cold something
that joe biden has experienced as
president before and therefore is still
fully in control and capable of carrying
out his duties as presidents of the
united states kimberly i should point
out one more thing we have here that my
apologies uh we have heard from the
first lady dr jill biden i forgot to
mention she has been uh traveling she
has tested negative for covid19 she is
resuming her full schedule or rather she
never interrupted her schedule she is in
the northern state of michigan she is
meeting with school children we
understand she has no intention of
changing her schedule in fact we
understand she is going to go to the
state of georgia following her stop in
michigan in other words uh she is
feeling fine has tested negative and
will continue to resume her duties as
first lady indeed we'll come back to you
of course uh kimberly with further
updates through the day for the moment
kimberly halcott there in washington dc